I don't know if any of you have seen a
diagram like this I was it was very very
popular about three years ago in 2012 at
a place called the Large Hadron Collider
okay Large Hadron Collider large you
know what large needs kawaii means you
know bank stuff together and a hand rod
is a particular kind of particle okay
our protons for instance if i recall
correctly our kind of had robbery now
what this diagram illustrates is what
happens when two Hydrans Kawhi at 99.999
I actually can't remember how he dies it
is it's a lot of ions percent of the
speed of light okay um objects with mass
like protons cannot actually travel at
the speed of light only particles
without mass can travel like that at
like photons it's like ah but at this
incredible speed which is more or less
the speed of light via the speed limit
of the universe these two particles are
racing around this ignore this circuit
that's why it's called large right in
fact I'll just really quickly find your
picture if you sweat right so this is an
aerial view obviously you can see how
far zoomed out we are because there are
you know this is tiny little dot C which
are like your towns or cities and so on
and you can see this is huge circuit
around here it's Underground okay and
around that circuit there are these
enormous magnets powered by incredible
amounts of electricity which just blow
the line that around here are
accelerating just like cars around a
racetrack our accelerated particles
around around and around until they go
this insane speed and then they collide
and they do this okay now why why build
this multi-billion dollar project which
took many buddy years to create many man
hours to do this well all was the
purpose okay and the answer was they
were searching for something they were
searching for something you might have
heard of this
it it's goes back in 2012 they
discovered this particle will get to
what discovery means in a second they
were looking for this thing called the
Higgs boson okay just like hadrons
bosons are a kind of particle okay and
um Peter Higgs i believe it was was a
physicist who theorized theorized the
existence of a particular kind of
particle you guys know about protons and
neutrons and electrons you might have
heard of our quarks up and down strange
and charm and all those kinds of things
Frank the Higgs boson was one of the
particles in the standard model of
physics standard model of physics and
here's the interesting thing right we
think again we're referring back to what
we were saying before we think of
science as an observing sort of thing
right you observe something you expect
you Pete and then you'll see some
patterns and that is exactly what it is
okay the vast majority of the standard
model of physics like protons and
neutrons and electrons we know about
because we have observed them right like
we we designed it could have over your
microscopes and instruments that allowed
us through solitaire principles to
observe most of the particles here okay
but but here's the mind-blowing thing
right what happened was when they put
together this bottle right it's a
mathematical model to mathematical
and so therefore in the same way that's
a like a young a biomechanical equation
if I gave you two crazy ladies I gave
you the greater lookit you guys know na
festa know there are two solutions to
this equation right the two solutions
are x equals 3 and x equals negative 3
you could put either of those numbers in
and you'll get a solution to the
equation okay now this is a very vastly
oversimplified way of illustrating that
in the standard model of physics there
are equations that govern what is going
on at how the particles interact with
each other okay but the equations that
govern draw you to certain conclusions
for instance they joined a conclusion
that oh I should have two solutions to
this right the standard model of physics
predicts a certain number of particles
including this guy right now it predicts
it but matically but it's never been
observed the reason it's never been
observed is because you need this
enormous apparatus the Large Hadron
Collider in order to create the
conditions that could possibly make one
of these actually observable to us in
the same way that the wavelengths of
light actually has a size so therefore
there's a physical limit to the size of
objects that you can see just by using
photons okay by using you know and I no
matter how powerful your microscope is
so therefore where you design
microscopes do not use photons they do
not use light they use electrons and so
we call them electron I think um
scanning electron microscopes right
instead of bouncing light off an object
they bounce electrons off and that's how
we can see much much smaller object okay
it exactly the same way the Large Hadron
Collider was built based on a
mathematical expectation
that something exists that we have never
ever observed right um millions of
billions of dollars and many many years
of work went into creating this thing
because of a back of vertical I
prediction right so mathematics has led
the way for science to then confirm this
right there did have to be you know yeah
billions and millions of millions of
these collisions happening every second
of every day for many months in order to
confirm that this particle actually did
exist okay but that's another
mathematical story which i'll save for
another day okay so I guess my point my
conclusion right is that if we come back
here we've got back this idea that there
are different ways of knowing there are
different ways of coming into knowledge
and being sure of what we know right
they all need to be complementary they
all need to be complementary but they
relate to each other in different ways
and that's why I say that when you think
about why is mathematics in stem okay
it's because mathematics pioneers the
way it's so many examples for science to
say okay what should we test it's not
the only pioneer but I'll it is what
which is led the way in a variety of
examples in I hope I've demonstrated
that to you this morning